مع دخوليا الشهر الخامس احتجاجات ايران
مستمره لبل تغذيها يوميا اسباب جديده من
مقدمتها الاعدامات ففي العاصمه طهران شهدت
مناطق مختلفه هتافات مناهضه لنظام واطلاق
سفارات الثوره كاحتجاج رمزي كما شكلت
مساكن الطلاب في العاصمه مسرحا لاحتجاجات
الليليه التي نددت باعدام رفاقهم مؤكده
البقاء حتى النهايات ياتي ذلك مشاهدينا
بالتزامن مع حكم بالاعدام اصدره القضاء
الايراني بحق ثلاثه مواطنين هم صالح
ملهاشمي ومشيد يعقوب وسعيد كاظم وفي
القضيه نفسها المعروفه باسم بيت اصفهان
حكم على لاعب كره القدم امير نصري نصر
ازاداني بالسجن سته وعشرين عاما
فهي العضويه في التجمعات غير القانونيه
بهدف الاخلالي بامن البلاد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جول
نعم
[موسيقى]